30 años después del conocido en Londres
como el miercoles negro, la libra volvió
a experimentar en septiembre de 2022 jornadas
de máxima tensión.
Si el 16 de septiembre de 1992 el mismísimo
banco central de Inglaterra tuvo que sucumbir
ante el asalto financiero capitaneado por
George Soros, en esta ocasión fue el propio
gobierno birtánico quien desató la tormenta.
El día 23 de septiembre de 2022 dio comienzo
una rocambolesca historia que terminó con
una reprimenda del FMI, una salida masiva
de inversores y una intervención de emergencia
del banco central para tratar de contener
el caos.
(Según Larry Summers, el Reino Unido podría
desencadenar una crisis global a medida que
la libra se derrumba mientras los rendimientos
de los bonos se disparan.
Market Watch)
En poco tiempo, la incertidumbre, las dudas,
el miedo y los peores auguros han rodeado
la economía británica.
En menos de un año el tipo de interés exigido
por el mercado para la deuda pública del
Reino Unido se multiplicó hasta por 10.
Tal y como podéis ver, si a finales de 2021
el gobierno británico podía emitir bonos
a 2 años pagando poco más del 0,4%, tras
la crisis de la Libra los tipos exigidos superan
el 4%.
Y para colmo podemos encontrarnos noticias
como está:
(Goldman Sachs advierte que la inflación
en Reino Unido podría superar el 22% el próximo
año.)
Y la pregunta es: Pero, ¿qué diantres está
pasando en Londres?
¿Por qué la libra se está desplomando?
¿Cómo se explica que el coste de la deuda
británica se haya disparado incluso por encima
de lo que tienen que pagar gobiernos en tan
mala situación financiera como los de España
o Italia?
Y la pregunta más importante de todas:
¿Qué demonios han hecho en el 10 de Downing
Street para desatar semejante tormenta?
Queridos amigos, amigas, en este vídeo vamos
a responder a todas estas preguntas, pero
antes, antes tenemos que saber dónde nos
encontramos exactamente.
Arranquemos.
[Pero antes, te pido un minuto para hacerte
una pregunta: ¿Te gusta lo que hacemos?
¿Te gustaría contibuir que este proyecto
siga creciendo y mejorando y al mismo tiempo
recibiri algunos beneficios exclusivos como
nuestro famosos boletín o regalos exclusivos?
Pues si es así, te invitamos a que te sumes
a nuestra comunidad de Patreon.
Nos ayudarás a llegar mucho más lejos y
podremos recorrer ese camino juntos.
Por ejemplo, gracias a todos los que nos apoyais
en esta comunidad en 2022 hemos podido lanzar
nuestro canal hermano de economía VisualEconomik.
Y ya os adelanto que estamos preparando muchas
cosas.
Os dejamos toda la info en la descripción.
Dicho esto continuemos.]
Reino Unido tiene un serio problema.
Desde la crisis financiera del 2008 su economía
no ha vuelto a ser la misma.
¿El último ejemplo?
Cómo podéis ver, se convirtió en el único
miembro del G7 cuya economía seguía siendo
a mediados del 2022 más pequeña que antes
de la pandemia.
Incluso la recuperación de un país como
Italia fue más fuerte.
Pero esto es tan solo la punta del iceberg.
(Desde la crisis financiera el PIB per cápita
real del Reino Unido apenas ha crecido y se
ha quedado muy por detrás de países como
Estados Unidos o Alemania.
Hablamos de una diferencia de casi 10 puntos.
Esta falta de crecimiento, menos de un 4%
en 14 años, hizo que los servicios públicos
tuvieran que financiarse cada vez más con
deuda y, también, con la mayor presión fiscal
de los últimos 40 años en el país.)
¿Y de quien fue la culpa?
Dee la productividad.
Para que os hagais una idea, entre el 2008
y el 2020 la productividad laboral en el Reino
Unido apenas creció un 0,4%, menos de la
mitad que el promedio de la OCDE.
En dinero contante y sonante esto supuso que
respecto a países como Francia o Alemania,
los británicos dejaron de ganar 4.000 dólares
por persona.
Y eso se nota.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Y por quédemonios crece
tan poco la productividad birtánica?
Pues entre otras cosas porque en este país
la inv versión empresarial, la inversión
en máquinas, fábricas, ordenadores, centros
de trabajo, etcétera, etcéra se encuentra
por los suelos.
¿No me creéis?
Pues fijaos.
Es la más baja de todos los países del G7
¡Hasta Italia les supera!
(La hiperespecialización financiera y la
incertidumbre causada por el Brexit han tenido
mucho que ver en esta mal desempeño.
Qué, además, ha tenido otras consecuencias.
Por ejemplo, esta hiperespecialización financiera,
la falta de inversión y la mala evolución
de la productividad han hecho que el Reino
Unido sea cada vez más dependiente del exterior,
lo que ha provocado que el déficit por cuenta
corriente supere el 8%.
Fundamentalmente como consecuencia del fuerte
déficit comercial.
Esto es, de que las importaciones superen
con mucho las exportaciones.)
A ver, un momento, esto no tiene que ser estrictamente
malo, siempre y cuándo las “exportaciones”
financieras sean capaces de compensarlo.
Y si no que se lo digan a Estados Unidos.
El problema es que para eso tienes que tener
la confianza de los inversores del resto del
mundo para que estos sigan comprando libras.
Si no es así te puedes meter de lleno en
una descomunal crisis.
Claro que esta no es la única consecuencia
de la infrainversión y mala evolución de
la productividad.
Otra consecuencia mucho más visible tiene
que ver con los salarios…
(Para que os hagais una idea, si en 2007 los
salarios británicos una vez descontada la
inflación eran más altos que los de Francia
o Alemania hoy ya son más bajos.
¿Por qué?
Pues porque entre los años 2010 y 2019 no
crecieron prácticamente nada.
Además, los hogares británicos de bajos
ingresos también son mucho más pobres, concretamente
un 22% y un 21% más pobres que los franceses
y los alemanes respectivamente.)
Y para colmo la deuda pública como porcentaje
del PIB ha batido su máximo nivel desde 1960.
Así que como veis, la economía británica
ni atraviesa su mejor momento ni es lo que
conoceríamos como boyante.
Los últimos años han sido más bien malos…
Pero, un momento, porque ahora la nueva Primer
Ministro, la sustituta de Boris Josh tiene
un plan.
Un plan que ha supuesto dar todo un carpetazo
en
la mesa. ¡Atentos!
(TRUSSNOMICS: EL PLAN)
Tan solo dos semanas después de hacerse con
las riendas del 10 de Downing Street, el nuevo
gobierno de Liz Truss dio un golpe en la mesa
y presentó un programa político que rompe
por completo con lo que ha sido la política
del Partido Conservador de la última década.
Liz Truss junto a su Canciller del Tesoro,
Kwasi Kwarteng, han diseñado una bomba de
recortes de impuestos, supresión de regulaciones
y gasto público para reactivar la economía
británica.Todo un chute de epinefrina para
hacer volver a latir al corazón económico
del país.
Según la propia Primera Ministro el objetivo
fundamental de este plan es acabar de cuajo
con las políticas de la redistribución para
centrarse por completo en la producción y
la productividad.
Es decir, dejar de pensar en cómo repartir
la riqueza y centrarse en crearla de nuevo.
C1 ("Lo que era completamente insostenible
era esta idea de que simplemente podíamos
gravar nuestro camino hacia la prosperidad
y olvidar el hecho de que habíamos alcanzado
un máximo de impuestos en 70 años.
¿Dónde queríamos que terminara eso?”.
Kwasi Kwarteng, Canciller del Tesoro)
Y, ojo, que no estamos ante una improvisación
ni un plan diseñado en el último minuto.
Para nada.
En 2012, tanto Liz Truss como Kwasi Kwarteng
fueron coautores del libro Britannia Unchained,
dónde ya desglosaban muchas de estas ideas.
Y, claro, ahora que se han hecho con el poder
han tenido la oportunidad de sacarlo adelante.
Ahora bien, ¿en qué consiste exactamente
esta supuesta vuelta - con muchos matices
- a la era de Tharcher?
Pues, veréis, por un lado el gobierno hizó
pública su intención de llevar a cabo el
mayor recorte de impuestos desde 1972:
(Esto incluye un montón de medidas como la
reversión del aumento del impuesto sobre
beneficios para dejarlo en el 19%.
La reducción en un punto del impuesto de
la renta para todos los contribuyentes;
La reducción de los impuestos sobre el capital,;
La reducción de las cotizaciones al seguro;
La congelación dee los impuestos especiales,
E incluso, inicialmente, - porque luego como
veremos lo han tenido que suspender - la reducción
en 5 puntos del tramo más alto del impuesto
de la renta.
Es decir, ningún cambio radical, pero sí
muchos pequeños cambios que juntos supondrán
el mayor recorte de impuestos llevado a cabo
por un gobierno británico en las últimas
5 décadas.)
Pero no todo va de impuestos.
El nuevo gobierno también se ha comprometido
a meter la tijera a las regulaciones.
Algo que por ejemplo ya han comenzado a hacer
al suspender los límites legales que existían
sobre los bonus del sector financiero.
Algo que fue establecido por la Unión Europea
en el año 2014.
Y es solo el principio.
C2 ("Acogemos con satisfacción la clara dirección
y el nuevo enfoque del canciller y su fuerte
respaldo al sector de los servicios financieros
como el catalizador de la economía del Reino
Unido.
Las medidas anunciadas hoy son el comienzo
de lo que se necesita para liberar toda la
fuerza del sector ". Comunicado de UK Finance,
la patronal financiera del Reino Unido)
También han anunciado la creación de numerosas
zonas económicas especiales a lo largo y
ancho de todo el país.
Zonas que contarán con algunas ventajas fiscales
y regulatorias y cuyo objetivo número 1 será
hacer crecer la inversión empresarial.
Es algo así como una evolución del proyecto
de puertos libres del gobierno de Johson del
que ya os hablamos aquí en VisualPolitik.
C3 ("Las zonas de inversión van más allá
del reciente régimen de puerto libre.
Además de mayores incentivos fiscales para
atraer a las empresas...
También reducen la burocracia y el prolongado
proceso de planificación, lo que a menudo
impide que las inversiones se produzcan".
Ben Houchen, Alcalde conservador de Tees Valley,
uno de los municipios beneficiados por este
plan)
Y luego…
A ver, os hago una pregunta: ¿Cuál es el
problema qué hoy por hoy más preocupa en
toda Europa?
3, 2, 1….
¡Exacto!
La energía…
O mejor dicho el coste de la energía.
C4 (“Debido a la invasión ilegal de Ucrania
por parte de Putin y el uso de la energía
como arma, fortalecer nuestra seguridad energética
es una prioridad absoluta”, Jacob Rees-Mogg,
Ministro de Energia del Reino Unido.)
Pues bien, aquí el gobierno de Truss lo tiene
muy claro: el Reino Unido tiene que conseguir
hacerse con una fuente de energía abundante
y al mismo tiempo barata.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Cómo esperan conseguirla?
Pues, además de mantener los nuevos planes
nucleares el gobierno también ha anunciado
el fin de la moratoria sobre el fracking.
Bajos impuestos, desregulación, zonas económicas
especiales y fracking, parece el sueño dorado
del Brexit.
Sobre todo, claro está, del Brexit defendido
por conservadores y liberales.
(Hablamos de un enorme paquete de lo que en
el mundo económico se conoce como políticas
de oferta con un objetivo muy claro: que la
economía británica se despierte de una vez
por todas y vuelva a crecer.
Lo que dadas las circunstancias puede tener
mucho sentido.
Al fin y al cabo ganar competitividad fue
el principal argumento a favor del Brexit.)
Pero…
Un momento.
Hemos comenzado este vídeo diciendo que el
plan del gobierno terminó con una intervención
de emergencia del banco central para frenar
el desplome de la Libra.
Y la pregunta es, ¿Por qué demonios los
mercados se han puesto tan nerviosos por un
recorte de impuestos?
Parece contraintuivo, ¿No os parece?
Pues, amigos, amigas, la respuesta tiene mucho
que ver con la segunda parte del plan del
Truss.
La parte que no tiene nada que ver con Margaret
Thatcher.
Junto a los recortes de impuestos, la desregulación,
el fracking y todo lo demás, el gobierno
también ha prometido un fortísimo incremento
del gasto público.
Concretamente en 2 ámbitos.
¿Recordais cuál es la mayor preocupación
de las familias, las empresas y los gobiernos
de toda Europa?
El coste de la energía.
Pues bien, Reino Unido no es una excepción.
Y sí, el fracking puede ayudar, pero no lo
suficientemente rápido.
Así que, ¿Sabéis que ha hecho el nuevo
gobierno británico?
Pues, anunciar un precio máximo a la energia
que pagan las familias y las empresas.
Una subvención que será pagada por el gobierno
y que como podéis ver en pantalla supone
el mayor plan de subvención energética de
toda Europa.
(El objetivo del gobierno es que la crisis
energética no afecte a la economía nacional.
No castigue a las empresas y a las familias
hasta que el país logre nuevas fuentes de
suministro barato.
El problema es que eso hace sospechar que
la subvención - y con ella la factura - podría
alargarse más de la cuenta.)
Pero eso ni siquiera es todo.
Al mismo tiempo el Secretario de Defensa,
Ben Wallece,ha confirmado lo que era un secreto
a voces:
El Reino Unido elevará su presupuesto militar
hasta los 100 mil millones de libras - más
de 110 mil millones de dólares - para el
final de esta década.
Esto supone más que duplicar el presupuesto
actual y elevar el esfuerzo militar hasta
el 3% del PIB en tan sólo 8 años.
Es decir, que cada año que pase el presupuesto
militar británico crecerá generosamente.
Lo que evidentemente supone más gasto, más
déficit y más deuda.
Pues bien, si tenemos en cuenta los recortes
de impuestos y los increntos de gasto, tenemos
algo así como una enorme bomba fiscal que
fue lo que desató la crisis.
Un enorme boquete que podría llevar a superar
los 80 mil millones de libras anuales durante
los próximos años.
Una enorme cantidad de dinero a sumar al ya
de por si importante agujero presupuestario.
Quizás por eso el gobierno no presentó su
plan ante la Oficina de Responsabilidad Presupuestaria.
¿Para qué?
¿Para qué lo criticaran?
El problema es que esta oficina, que por cierto
fue puesta en marcha por el consevador David
Cameron, tiene precisamente esa función.
Ahora bien, ¿Qué efectos puede tener este
plan para la economía británica?
¿Es que acaso los mercados no se fían de
que Londres pueda pagar sus facturas?
Pues bien, veámoslo.
T2 (EL PÁNICO)
Amigos, amigas, el plan de Truss puede tener
cierto sentido, pero supone una enorme apuesta
dónde los resultados no están asegurados.
Entre otras cosas, porque pese a todo, existen
serias dudas de que lo anunciado sea suficiente
como para espolear a lo bestia la economía
británica.
Así que la presentación del plan tuvo 3
efectos inmediatos:
Primero, la libra se desplomó y alcanzó
el nivel más bajo frente al dólar.
Segundo, el rendimiento de la deuda pública
se disparó por encima, incluso, de la deuda
de países como Italia, Grecia o España.
N3 (Máxima tensión en Reino Unido: la libra
se hunde a mínimos de 1971 y su bono bate
el 4,2%.
El Confidencial)
Y tercero, con las dos consecuencias anteriores
estuvo a punto de producirse un enorme crack
financiero con los fondos de pensiones.
(¿Por qué?
Pues porque como la rentabilidad de la renta
fija ha sido tan baja durante los últimos
años, estos fondos se lanzaron a invertir
más y más en derivados sobre los tipos de
interés para intentar mejorar sus niveles
de rentabilidad.
Y, claro, se desató la tormenta, de repente,
sus derivados perdieron valor con lo que tuvieron
que incrementar las garantías que se exigen
para operar con estos productos.
Lo que los condujó a una crisis de liquidez
y a tener que vender activos a toda velocidad.
Y en cierto modo eso fue lo que obligó al
banco central a intervenir con un plan de
emergencia de 65 mil millones de libras.
Con esta intervención y la promesa de presentar
un plan de estabilidad presupuestaria se calmaron
los nervios…
Y con ello parcialmente la libra se ha recuperado
… Por ahora.)
Pero, ¿por qué se produjo tanto miedo en
los mercados?
¿Es que acaso a los inversores nos les gustan
los bajos impuestos?
Pues lo cierto es que podemos encontrar varios
motivos:
En primer lugar, el enorme boquete presupuestario
que supondrá este plan será financiado con
deuda.
Y ojo que hablamos de una cantidad que durante
los próximos años puede llegar a suponer
más de 300 mil millones de libras de deuda
adicional.
El problema es que ya no hablamos de tipos
casi 0 como ocurría hace poco tiempo.
Ahora el rendimiento de la deuda pública
británica supera el 4%....
Es decir que el país tendrá que empezar
a pagar muchísimos más intereses…
Lo que emborronará aún más las cuentas
públicas cada año.
C5 ("Existe un riesgo real de que los inversores
internacionales pierdan la confianza en el
gobierno del Reino Unido y eso conduzca a
una crisis de la libra esterlina [..] "El
mercado se pregunta '¿cómo vas a pagar por
esto?".
Mark Dowding, director de inversiones de BlueBay
Asset Management.)
Segundo, porque se teme que este plan pueda
alimentar aún más la inflación y la pérdida
de valor de la libra, lo que incrementaria
el coste de las importaciones y el deficit
por cuenta corriente.
Lo que podría provocar más inflación y
más caídas de la libra.
Y vuelta empezar.
Tercero, si este escenario se produce, al
mismo tiempo que el gobierno mantiene su bomba
fiscal, el banco central se puede ver obligado
a subir más los tipos de interés para luchar
contra la inflación y estabilizar el precio
de la libra.
Los tipos más altos podrían afectar el crecimiento
ya que podrían reducir la demanda de crédito
y los proyectos de inversión.
Además elevarían aún más el coste de la
deuda del gobierno…
Complicando aún más el panorama fiscal.
¿Lo veis?
Lo que temen los mercados es que este plan
pudiera terminar causando una enorme espiral
de crisis.
Ahora bien, entonces, ¿Por qué demonios
lo han presentado?
Pues básicamente porque lo que el gobierno
espera es que gracias a este plan la economía
británica se despierte, se comporte mejor
que la del resto de Europa y que entonces
el crecimiento diluya o evite los problemas.
Sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta que el gobierno
espera congelar el gasto público a medio
plazo.
C6 ("Los mercados se mueven todo el tiempo.
Es muy importante mantener la calma y centrarse
en la estrategia a largo plazo".
Kwasi Kwarteng, Canciller del Tesoro)
Y, a ver, ¿qué queréis que os diga?La economía
británica probablemente necesita este tipo
de revulsivo…
El problema es que quizás el gobierno ha
sido demasiado ambicioso.
Al fin y al cabo conciliar la bajada de impuestos
con un fortísimo incremento del gasto público
puede no ser la mejor idea del mundo.
De momento la presión ha sido tan alta que
el gobierno ha tenido que dar marcha atrás
y congelar la reducción del tipo máximo
del impuesto de la renta…
Al menos por ahora.
Pero, no nos engañemos.
De una forma u otra, quizás más progresiva,
este es el camino que el Brexit les obliga
a seguir.
Si el Reino Unido quiere tener éxito tiene
que convertirtse en un lugar muy competitivo
en el mundo.
Y para lograrlo solo hay un camino.
Pero llegados hasta aquí turno para ti: ¿Qué
te parece el plan del gobierno británico?
¿Creés que el Trussnomics tendrá éxito
o por contra supondrá el fin de la etapa
de gobiernos conservadores?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
ahora si este vídeo te ha resultado interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik
si es que aún lo has hecho.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.